c'est mon mari il a
disparu je suis terriblement inquiète
c'est juste que Fred n'est jamais parti aussi
longtemps avant combien de temps a-t-il disparu
depuis l'enterrement eh bien je peux commencer tout de
suite tu es détective privé mon
métier est très compliqué d'accord c'est
nuancé
vous êtes des gens debout et facturez de l'argent ouais
triste n'est-ce pas combien factureriez-vous
pour être dans mon amie Janet combien
vous avez obtenu 20 dollars c'est bien cette
conversation est terminée la foule essaie
d'étendre son opération à Los Angeles d'une
manière ou d'une autre mon  ma fille Mia est impliquée
s'il vous plaît trouvez-la j'ai vu cette fille
ce qu'il y a dedans pour moi oh nous pouvons le faire de
manière simple comment vous le faites actuellement de
manière simple
quoi qu'il soit arrivé de m'offrir 20
dollars c'est la récession c'est un
haut  -l'affaire du profil a fait les journaux
où est Amelia que se passe-t-il d'autre oh
tu sais qu'il y a un gars je vais nous tuer
je suis un peu de la merde hé pouvez-vous vous comporter comme un
professionnel
elle est en danger mec faites quelque chose à
ce sujet elle est morte qu'est-ce que vous t  Je pense que toutes les personnes
impliquées dans cette affaire étaient en train de mourir ce
n'est pas toi tu n'es pas un meurtrier
tue juste trois personnes tu sais ce que je
dis au fond de toi tu viens ici tu
me bats
ça fait partie du boulot je l'accepte mais pourquoi
l'avez-vous fait, vous m'avez énervé
avant que nous allions résoudre le crime du
siècle,
occupons-nous du cadavre en décomposition, obtenons un plan